welcome back everybody post game press
conferences always bring us some of the
best moments after all the action on
sunday and so as we wind down here on
peacock let's hear from coach snoop as
he steps to the podium
hey hey hey what's going on y'all
another exciting week in nfl week 10 is
in the books
taking questions right now feel free to
ask come on
yeah back there does the bills win today
mean uh that they're back on track uh
the bill's win was
merely they played the jets what would
you say to the lions to motivate them to
get their first win of the season man i
ain't gonna say nothing about the lions
next question is still a gang fool coach
snoop which two teams will be joining
you at the super bowl uh
i would like to be politically correct
and say
la and pittsburgh that makes sense
coach sue if you coach a lot of youth
football any uh interest in coaching an
nfl team
there's a lot of interest in um coaching
an nfl team we just got to be the coach
that's willing to take a chance on
somebody like me to put me in a position
to you know exercise my skills coaching
follow-up question how soon will you be
taking over for urban meyer
oh that's crazy i wouldn't take that job
i'll give it to my homeboy little duval
hey coach knew what do you think about
so many teams going forward on fourth
down this season in the nfl i love it
when a team goes for it on fourth down
i'm an offensive coordinator so i feel
like i don't bring no punters to the
table no way we didn't pack a punter so
shout out to all the teams going for it
on fourth down and punters
don't take it personal we don't need you
coach snoop in the uh darren williams
versus frank gore boxing match who comes
out on top damn that's my first time
hearing about that frank gore versus
darren williams the point guard used to
play with the mavericks
i'm gonna have to go with franklin
delano gore cause frankie d
went to the university of miami and i
know he got some goon in him
305 in the house coach snoop what should
they rename the washington football team
well i know go go music is big in dc
so maybe the uh washington go gals
[Applause]
coach stoop i heard a rumor that you and
dre might play baby shark at the super
bowl halftime show
baby shark baby shark
i don't know i don't know my parts to
that i'm at the rehearsal coach coach
snoop coach snoop if you could change
one nfl rule what would it be
no drug testing
is there any other questions coach coach
coach what's going on for dinner tonight
what will i be having for dinner tonight
i will be having
a bologna sandwich with barbecue chips
say man y'all stay locked and loaded and
uh see you guys next week week 11. y'all
stay safe keep it locked right here we
outta here peace
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports